ce conte ici c'est le vert actuellement
entreposé michel marquis est un ardent
défenseur de la consigne il ne comprend
pas pourquoi le québec tergiverse au
vermont tout est consigné à l'état new
york tout est consigné l'état du match
auxerre
tout est consigné on ramasse d'adler ont
reçu que 100 % bien ici au québec on
s'abstient d'accord pour mettre une
conscience une bouteille de vin c'est
complètement ridicule
en attendant il vient d'investir près de
3 millions de dollars pour moderniser
son usine afin de redonner de la valeur
à cette montagne de verre non consignés
fruit de la collecte sélective
c'est justement le genre d'initiative
que la société des alcools du québec
voudrait voir se multiplier
tout plutôt que de devoir elle même
consigné ses bouteilles
la société d'état a d'ailleurs commandé
une étude sur la consigne
le constat la mise en place des
infrastructures nécessaires à une telle
initiative coûterait cher très cher
250 millions de dollars un montant qui
serait plus élevé si la saq consignait
les bouteilles dans ces établissements à
prendre beaucoup d espace nous on des
espaces locatifs si on n'est pas
propriétaire donc aller chercher un
plusieurs mètres carrés additionnel pour
acquérir des bouteilles mais évidemment
faudra briser nos beaux sons sont à deux
ça quand ils ont la place ils ont le
système de logistique inverse donc pour
la récupération des contenants
donc tout est possible pour la
récupération des contenants dans
certaines succursales à québec le
gouvernement analyse toutes les options
quoi qu'on fasse ce qu'on aide qu'on
comprenne l'option a b ou c
il va avoir des coûts faut pas non plus
penser que ça ne coûte absolument rien
de améliorer la récupération de divers
milieux
à ceux qui prônent la modernisation des
centres de tri michel marquis répond
ceci ça fait combien d'années qu'on dit
moderniser les centres de tri ici comme
ailleurs le vert en provenance de la
cueillette sélective est inverse de
piètre qualité
on ne peut pas faire un produit à valeur
ajoutée avec un verre comme ça il est
prêt à essayer mais n'offrent aucune
garantie
ici maxime bertrand radio canada saint
jean sur richelieu